[Music]
normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government we
have the story from ABC News Kevin
McCarthy resigning from Congress after
being Ed house speaker so the the story
came out yesterday at the end of the
month he will resign he says I've
decided to depart the house at the end
of this year to serve America in new
ways this is really funny because uh
there was a tweet it was a video of uh
was a tweet from him saying I will not
quit and it is now community noted on
Twitter saying he just quit brutal so uh
here's the funny thing this came out
last night nobody cared yeah yeah nobody
nobody cared that uh former speaker just
announced his resignation but uh I think
what Matt Gates did was fantastic I'm
curious uh your thoughts uh rep cran on
what went down and uh whether you think
this is all good bad well yeah I mean
obviously Matt deserves a lot of credit
Matt would you know took uh I think took
the brunt of that for sure but there
were eight of us right there were eight
Republicans that moved against our own
speaker um and so for sure I think that
it was a good idea cuz I was one of them
right um and and the reason the reason
guys like I like I said is because I
didn't get in I didn't get into this I
don't leave my family three weeks out of
the month with my two young daughters
because I like Washington DC or I like
putting on a suit or I ever wanted to be
called a congressman right I I'm
terrified with what my kids are going to
be left with and I look at the
trajectory we're on and it's not
sustainable this house of is going to
collapse and PE most people up there
don't take it seriously it's it's it's
weird man it's dystopian there's there's
there's two trains of thought on that I
think everybody agrees the House of
Cards is going to collapse yeah and then
you've got some Republicans who are like
guys let's try and fix this and then
you've got I'd say most Republicans and
Democrats being like how much can we
loot from the coffers before the before
the cards come crashing down yeah we and
we call it the uni party up there right
anytime anytime something serious needs
to get moved the uni party moves in lock
step and it is Republicans and Democrats
people get pissed at me all Republicans
get pissed at me all the time you know
I'll get calls from donors or why is Eli
why are you why are you attacking
Republicans you know you need to be
attack you need to be fighting against
Democrats that's just one layer to the
fight it is an important layer to the
fight but it goes It goes a lot deeper
than that and if we don't if we don't
acknowledge the own you know the own
stink the own you know our own problems
within our own party this thing's never
going to get it's never going to get
fixed and you know it's like I I'm just
glad that there are there are people up
there who I've seen even in this last
Congress the 118th Congress who
repeatedly are willing to throw caution
to the wind put their political career
career on the chopping block and be like
hey let's go let's do something that's
never been done and let's buck the
system and so you know I don't know
where that leads Tim I I'm not I'm not a
super optimistic guy my faith isn't in
the federal government for for good
reason but uh you know I I do think it's
important I mean Matt Matt was talking
about this billion dooll IOU machine
that Kevin McCarthy builds up where he
goes all these all these donors
basically get get are hey we're going to
give money to your pack we're going to
help you get re-elected you're going to
control uh uh basically the Republican
party in in the house and then when he
gets Ed all those IUS become toilet
paper so you know this this machine of
favors in DC gets shattered I got to
imagine Kevin McCarthy was sweating
bullets the whole time cuz he's not
going to be able to pay back any of
these favors he's an indentured servant
for the rest of his life yeah I honestly
don't know and like you know here's the
thing like if you if you met Kevin and
you hung out with him and you didn't
know he was the speaker of the house
you'd probably be like this guy's pretty
cool like I'd have a beer with him you
know and uh but that being said when you
look at when you look at what was going
on and when you look at how he was
leading the the party there there was no
desire to change course at all I've
heard from too many people that he
backstabbed their campaigns that there
were there were uh populists America
first they were Trump supporting for
sure and and and any anybody in that not
I shouldn't say anybody but most people
in that spot would use their power and
influence to back candidates that are
going to fall in line and do what you're
told and you know it's like that's one
of the biggest knock I'm a military guy
that's one of the biggest knocks on
Military guys um I remember when I
started going up to DC Tim some of the
old Republicans looked at me and they're
like you know Eli you military guys get
up here and you you don't really fight
too hard you know you kind of just fall
in line and do what you're told and I I
said I know um but that's when you look
at your chain of command as the people
back home the 750,000 people that sent
you there it it's it's you know it's
it's different than seeing the
Republican party or the Democrat Party
as your new chain of command right and
that's the problem with too many
politicians they see they see their
party as their chain of command and they
just follow in lock step and they do
what they're told how's uh life with
Mike Johnson the new speaker how's it
been I mean honestly we're not it's it's
not it's really not uh that much
different in that we're still pretty
much on the same trajectory maybe a
couple degrees off um and I think that
most of us that were involved in Ting
Kevin with the motion to vacate um
believed that that's how it was going to
be just because whoever speaker is
really a representative of the party and
the party is not conservative it's just
not you know um that being said you know
he has done a couple he has done a
couple good things and so like when he
released some of the January 6 tapes I
think that was a good that was a good
thing I I think you know he's serious
about moving forward with you know this
Biden you know impeachment that's a good
thing but he's shown with you know the
CR the continuing resolution that funds
the government at the same levels and
even right now with the ndaa and fisa
that you know we're probably going to
continue to go on on the same path with
some of those things is it because if he
just was like I'm going to make a bill
of getting rid of the CR that everyone
in the party be like then no one's going
to vote for it dude so like he has so
what they do you know what they do is
they scare they scare anybody that gets
into leadership right like the
intelligence Community right now is
telling Mike Johnson hey if you let if
you let fisa lapse or you you reform it
and and fisa go down for even a little
while and you have right now who who's
out there saying that we have more
terrorist threats than we ever have
before Christopher Ray right so so
Mike's making these decisions the
intelligence Community is scaring the
snot out of him saying hey man if you
let F of the laps um and there's a
terrorist attack the blood's on your
hands and that's what they do constantly
up there it's it's constantly like if
you try and change things whether it's
with spending or a government shutdown
or you know make adjustments or
reforming fisa they have a way to scare
you back into into
line they're going to they're not only
they're going to blame you but they're
going to go ahead and they're going to
accuse you of trying to make it so that
these things can happen no I think it's
worse than that you're probably right I
think it's worse than that when uh when
when was it Chuck Schumer said that the
intelligence agencies have six waves
from Sunday from coming after you Donald
Trump yeah and then they accuse Trump of
being a Soviet spy like no I'm not no
Soviet literally from the ' 80s the guy
the guy Jonathan CH goes NBC and says
Trump may have been an asset of the
Russians since the 80s they they they do
multiple impeachments they do criminal
charges everything you you see them
throwing at Trump then I don't think
they go to Mike Johnson and they say
look we got security issues don't let us
down I think they they sit down at the
desk and they say how how's it going
how's the family I I got something for
you and they plot a picture of JFK and
they slide it across the table and say
how you doing yeah can you imagine that
like literally all they have to do is
slide a picture of JFK if someone from
CIA
shows up at your house and they slide a
picture of JFK across the table at you
and say how you doing like everyone's
sweating everyone starts sweating yeah
they slide a picture of JFK that's it
they don't got to say anything yeah the
implic it's the implication right and
and I'm not saying the implication is
true I'm just saying you know it says a
lot so the intelligence when you say the
intelligence how do you phrase it the
intelligence Network or commun Community
is that who's running our government
well I I don't think it's that
simplistic I think it's a mix it's a
mixed bag right there's a lot there's a
lot of different influences on the
government right you also have your
lobbyists your special interest groups
right you have you have outside Global
influences that are obviously affecting
our government as well um I mean there's
it's not as simplistic as one you know
entity um you know basically running our
government why is a special interest I
hear this stupid word so it's just a
business it's a corporation absolutely
absolutely what about the pharmaceutical
industry green piece and they so special
interest is like a way to spin it to
make specially interesting no no no
special interest is an umbrella term for
a variety of organizations that want a
specific goal to to be met so Green
Piece is a special interest not well you
say but they want the same goal no no no
no locki Martin is a special interest
group they Lobby on behalf of themselves
Green Piece is a special special
interest group they Lobby on behalf of
themselves no one's going to sit there
and be like the problem we have is let
me pull out 18,000 pages of every single
organization ever that's lobbying the
government special interest groups
powerful organizations from the private
and public sector and nonprofits that
are lobbying government to make things
happen some are more powerful than
others and then if they say it's a
lobbyist that could be just a guy but if
it's a special interest group that's
it's a lobbyist the lobbyist would be
the individual that's actually trying to
get the politician to do whatever it is
that they the the special interest group
wants the group is the special interest
the lobby the individual and to be fair
I mean there there are there are good
lobbyists right that are lobbying for
good things but often times you know
it's uh you know it Ventures into
corruption and you know seeking things
that are so front sight focus on just
taking care of one
industry Ian you my firearms guy got it
over here and I will I will and I will
do it again so when when you when you
talk to someone who's in Congress and
you're like you got to get graphine I
was about to say that we were talking
about the house of CS we need graphing
lattice to reinforce
theor it's carbon it's carbon powder
basically uh you make it from any kind
of carbon and they figured out on the
you get like plastic trash and hit it
with 7,000 de electricity too far ahead
it's like 21st century steel it's going
to be the next big building material
it's it's it's a one-dimensional sheet
of carbon hexagonally latticed which has
amazing properties when manipulated so
well can it's a super conductor yes and
capacitor you can use it as like a
touchscreen battery wallpaper um they
put it in in car well I'll give you the
real simple so Ian's obsessed with this
stuff but the the reason I brought it up
was to make the point that lobbying a
lot of people have this view of lobbying
as this like prestigious thing and it's
like dude it literally means you argued
to a member of Congress yeah they used
to stand in the lobby literally that's
why they would call that after and then
when they came out of the proceeding
they'd be like hey for the sake of Ian's
griffine uh one thing they they started
doing is they put it in batteries okay
and so what that does is when you're
charging a battery the graphine carries
the charge evenly across the battery so
it charges rapidly so uh uh I think the
newer cell phones that come out could
could charge to full in like 10 minutes
wow so you can you can buy these
graphine Polymer batteries you you ever
get one of those mobile batteries you
buy the Walgreens whatever plug your
phone in yeah they now they now have
graphine uh lithium batteries that you
can charge that battery pack in 15
minutes and it'll give your phone two
hours of charge wow you can put in
concrete and it'll make it three times
stronger you can put it in like this is
just bulk graphine where you just
shattered into powder you can also make
sheets of it like Tim was talking about
they can be used as Electronics which is
more complicated to produce at the
moment and this is literally lobbying
but what I really want to sell you on is
hydrogen fuel because if we if we want
to reinforce that house of cards we need
a new GDP model and it's I think it's
based on hydrogen fortunately you can
turn the oil into graphine so we don't
have to upend the oil industry maybe I I
don't know I think uh Fusion Energy is
is promising reach ignition now we just
got to capture that energy so and
nuclear but out of rice they're making
hydrogen fuel like crazy right now with
carbon trash they'll hit it with a laser
they produce a kilogram of hydrogen fuel
and then they have $4.50 left over of
this stuff so it's actually profitable
to create the hydrogen thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net